[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le camp
vite et des territoires la france des
consignes et nous verrons dans ce
journal télévisé que tous les différents
acteurs de la vie économique et local du
territoire se remettent à espérer la
france ed confine donc direction l'île
de france pour commencer avec paris et
sa région qui attendait cette décision
avec une très grande impatience
tous les restaurants donc ouvrir cette
semaine les équipes de télé 78 sont
allés à montigny-le-bretonneux dans les
yvelines pour recueillir quelques
témoignages sur cette réouverture
regarder en salle ou en terrasse
les restaurateurs peuvent à présent
reposer cette fameuse question
suite aux annonces des manuels macron
même si le temps n'est pas encore au
beau fixe
la réouverture des salles divise la
clientèle sera que c'est quand même plus
agréable de s'asseoir de se poser de
manger sur place mais c'est mieux d'être
dehors je pense c'est à dire libre
partie nous manque les gestes barrières
sont respectés la distance et respectez
donc ça va y'a pas de en terrasse ou
intérieure se passe pas un problème
surpris par les annonces du président ce
restaurateur de montigny le bretonneux a
eu à peine le temps de se préparer pour
la réouverture
il a rappelé dimanche soir ces onze
salariés pour revenir travailler à temps
plein ce lundi matin
pour lui c'est un soulagement de pouvoir
ouvrir on attendait depuis tellement
longtemps de retrouver un peu une vie
normale
né au moins quand même de d'ouvrir entre
et venant on peut s'arrêter n'aurait pu
s'organiser mieux
nous on travaille essentiellement
quasiment que les produits frais donc
pour s'approvisionner c'est pas évident
une table sur deux est occupé par des
clients et sur ses deux salles une seule
est ouverte ce qui représente 40
couverts sur 80 depuis le 2 juin il a dû
investir pour pouvoir accueillir plus de
monde en terrasse va terrasse derrière
je me mette beaucoup de monde mais comme
nos clients ne savaient pas et que la
copropriété a nous a alloué sept espaces
et qu'il tende de d'acheter le matériel
parce que encore une fois quand vous
allez faire des achats pour une terrasse
vous n'avez pas forcément tout
l'équipement forcément notre activité
est très impacté
en tout cas on espère d'ici la fin
d'année retrouvez un écran
fonctionnement plutôt normal pour
rouvrir totalement les restaurateurs
devront respecter un protocole strict 10
clients maximum par table
rendre le port du masque obligatoire
pour se déplacer dans le restaurant et
espacer les tables d'un mètre voilà près
de france nous allons à présent à
bordeaux où les parents et les
enseignants restent dans l'expectative
après les annonces du président de la
république lundi prochain l'école sera
obligatoire donc pour tous les élèves
vous allez voir dans ce reportage de
dominique parmentier de tv7 la chaîne du
groupe sud ouest que le sentiment est
plutôt mitigé chez les parents et chez
les enseignants l'école à la maison
c'est fini tous les écoliers les
collégiens devront reprendre le chemin
de l'école à partir de lundi au lieu des
4 mètres carrés on passe à un mètre
latérale entre chaque élève a priori les
autres mesures sanitaires seront
maintenus pour le syndicat majoritaire
des enseignants du primaire ce retour à
l'école pour tous c'est à la fois un
soulagement et une source d'inquiétude
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour les
enfants et pour l'école ans on est
content de voir les élèves revenir en
revanche on se pose quand même beaucoup
de questions par rapport aux mesures
sanitaires et de distanciation sociale
qui qui qui va falloir continuer à
observer et on se demande si ça va être
possible de le faire dans toutes les
écoles il ya quand même beaucoup
d'écoles avec des classes exigus
il ya beaucoup d'écoles où les
sanitaires sont en sous nombre et où ça
va être compliqué notamment pour le
lavage des mains et puis il ya la
question des bureaux tout simplement du
mobilier qui parfois au risque de ne pas
être suffisant pour tenir les élèves
malgré tout à distance de respect des
conditions de sanitaires pour la
fédération des parents d'élèves le
retour de tous les enfants à l'école
c'est une bonne nouvelle mais là aussi
des questions se posent comment ce
retour va t'il être possible puisqu'il
ya encore du flou autour de l'allègement
du vha des procédures sanitaires et pour
nous il faut être très attentif au fait
que ces gestes barrières ils sont
essentielles puisque c'est un élément
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui la situation
s'est améliorée 100% de retour ça vous
paraît pas faisable 22 juin ben ça
paraît compliqué ou alors ça veut dire
qu'il n'y a plus du tout de protocole
sanitaire et ce qui paraît de notre
point de vue il envisageable tous
attendent aujourd'hui des précisions
quant aux lycéens ils ont
prioritairement mais partiellement
repris les cours dans les lycées
professionnels
pour les autres cela reste à
l'appréciation de chaque établissement
conséquence de cette fin de crise les
frontières avec nos voisins européens se
lève peu à peu depuis le début de la
semaine
c'est le cas notamment avec nos cousins
belges pour les habitants des hauts de
france évidemment cette nouvelle a ravi
les habitants effet redémarré bien sûr
le commerce entre nos deux pays
noam huclin notre confrère de wéo la
chaîne de la voix du nord dans les
hautes france en a profité pour faire
quelques courses
regardez de la france à la belgique il
n'ya qu'un pas vous voyez là je suis en
france il suffit que je traverse cette
rue et je suis désormais en belgique
durant trois mois ne pouvions plus
traverser cette frontière depuis ce
lundi 15 juin
ces deux nouveaux possibles et
évidemment ici tout le monde est content
notamment les français puisqu'ils
peuvent de nouveau venir en belgique
faire leurs achats et écoutez les il
était notamment tout à l'heure au micro
de jérôme blais qu'on a toutes nos
habitudes en belgique le tabac le
carburant et puis même les denrées qu'on
trouvera en belgique
c'est d'ailleurs les commerces et le
plus proche de chez nous donc oui on est
très content
on a nos habitudes en belgique très
content oui ça nous permet de faire
quelques achats qui malheureusement
était restée en suspens avec avec la
fermeture ça nous a manqué oui tout à
fait non nous sommes très contents et ça
permet de faire une petite balade en
famille est ici à la frontière la
clientèle est majoritairement française
durant ce confinement il n'y avait donc
plus de français des chiffres d'affaires
qui ont chuté pour les commerçants des
commerçants très heureux d'ouvrir de
nouveau leurs portes ce lundi 15 juin à
écouter les une très bonne nouvelle en
effet ça fait des mois très durs pour
nous avec les magasins fermés on n'a pas
l'habitude
donc nous sommes très heureux de pouvoir
recueillir les nos voisins quoi dès les
premières heures déjà beaucoup de monde
oui tout de suite ce magasin a ouvert 8
heures et tout de suite il y avait plein
de monde donc des français surtout des
français
nous avons à la plupart de notre
clientèle c'est des français donc vous
comprenez maintenant pourquoi ça a été
dur on avait le droit d'ouvrir en
belgique à partir du 11 mai on a dû le
fermer quelques magasins comme il n'y
avait pas des gens coin donc français
contenter de venir plutôt que de venir
les jours d'avant alors qu'on appellera
traverser la frontière
howe est comme toujours oui bien sûr ils
venaient dans le magasin mais c'est
peut-être il voulait essayer d'être les
dépêchés ils étaient voulait faire très
vite
parce que oui il ne voulait pas entendre
quoi c'était juste pour le tabac et puis
tout de suite repartir mais il y avait
plein d'appels
il y avait eu plein de messages sur
facebook et sur mail on a toujours fait
il est client si vous venez avant le 15
vous risquez d'avoir une amende je pense
que les gens ont quand même apprécier et
à une vingtaine de kilomètres de mena à
mouscron plus précisément dans cette
grande jardinerie bien connue des
frontaliers les français sont de nouveau
de retour et en nombre comme en
témoignent ses nombreuses plaques
d'immatriculation françaises sur le
parking voilà proche des hauts de france
l'angleterre pour nos voisins
britanniques les mesures sanitaires sont
encore très drastiques
toutes les personnes arrivant par mr par
terre par air sont mises en quarantaine
pour trois semaines
c'est une mesure qui inquiète bien sûr
les professionnels du tourisme dans nos
stations à nous
et s'il était s'annonce compliquée
l'hiver est déjà lui aussi dans tous les
esprits
victoria lopes pour la chaîne 8 mont
blanc nos partenaires sur place est
allée à leur rencontre à morzine dans
les alpes regardez ce reportage
les portes du soleil attire chaque année
des milliers de voyageurs britanniques
très prisé par les vététistes l'été la
station village de morzine s'apprête à
vivre une saison perturbée attendre et
voir comment cela se passe f
je pense que ça dépendra beaucoup des
règles de quarantaine et de leur
évolution
si elle est levée beaucoup de monde
viendra sinon c'est sûr qu'il n'y aura
personne les règles de quarantaine voilà
de quoi des pentes de nombreux
commerçants hôteliers aux restaurateurs
dans la station depuis le 8 juin
le royaume uni a en effet imposé une
quarantaine pour tous les voyageurs
arrivant sur le sol britannique
par mesure de réciprocité la france a
décidé d'inviter les britanniques à
s'isoler pendant 14 jours à leur arrivée
sur le territoire français dans ces
conditions les vacances deviennent un
véritable casse-tête est une vraie
inquiétude pour les acteurs du tourisme
en savoie mont blanc
c'est notre deuxième clientèle
internationale était juste derrière les
néerlandais
donc ils viennent en nombre sur notre
territoire que ce soit en montagne au
bord des lacs pour pratiquer toutes les
activités adore qu'on peut proposer
donc on a un peu un double effet cet été
avec à la fois le break site qui est
compliqué à gérer pour eux et puis et
puis cette quarantaine qui a été imposé
à devait depuis lundi
elle gère une entreprise de location de
chalets à morzine 90 % de sa clientèle
et britanniques à chaque jour on a des
clients qui nous demande on peut
transférer les vacances jusqu'à l'année
prochaine
on peut annuler on peut voir les autres
options et on essaie de trouver les
autres options par exemple venir à plus
tard dans l'été mois d'août peut-être
mois de septembre bon il va rester
ouvert cet été jusqu'à
20-20 ce 21 septembre et on trouve les
solutions comme ça ahmed sait pas faire
c'est s'il était inquiète c'est aussi et
surtout la saison d'hiver qui sera
déterminante
c'est dans divers camps ont fait 80 % de
notre chiffre d'affaires
et si un deuxième conflit mois c'est
difficile d'imaginer comment on peut
continuer l'ouverture des frontières
intérieures de l'europe le 15 juin le
donnera peut-être un peu d'espoir aux
professionnels du tourisme
voilà pendant cette crise sanitaire bien
sûr tous les soirs à 20h vous vous en
rappelez vous les applaudissent y est
depuis chez vous pour leur rendre
hommage et bien le personnel soignant
s'est mobilisé cette semaine un peu
partout dans toute la france
de nombreuses manifestations à travers
le pays pour demander plus de moyens
pour l'hôpital public
comme vous pouvez le voir sur ces images
tournées par deux confrères à epinal 2
via vosges via vosges d'ailleurs et ses
équipes qui ont recueilli quelques
témoignages de leurs représentantes
regarder on encore déjà de moyens de
personnel ça n'a fait qu'accentuer les
choses
[Musique]
il est grand temps que les choses
changent on n'est pas à l'abri que ça
revienne que ça recommence
on nous renvoie toujours qu'on a une
vocation qu'on est dans le dos de soi et
caetera et donc ça c'est quelque chose
qui nous colle à la peau et on veut plus
de ça on veut vraiment être reconnu par
rapport à nos compétences et nos
responsabilités je vais vous dire
quelque chose je suis contente de partir
ça devrait pas mais je suis contente
quand même de partir alors que je pense
que c'est un métier merveilleux
soignants c'est un métier auxi on donne
on reçoit mais on est on nous demande de
plus en plus de faire des actes et des
dents la rentabilité voilà quelques
bonnes nouvelles maintenant dans ce
grand jt des territoires pour les
personnes âgées notamment les gens les
plus fragiles
c'est une bonne nouvelle et visites sont
désormais autorisées dans les ehpad et
raphaël ton driot gauthier qui s'est
rendu à la maison de retraite du pôle
saint-hélier dans le centre-ville de
rennes a pu constater que les choses
s'améliorer même si beaucoup de
questions se posent sur les conditions
d'accueil des familles comme
l'expliquent ce reportage réalisé par
nos confrères de tv rennes regarder cela
fait plus de trois mois que stéphane
piquet n'a pas rencontré sa famille
ce résident de la maison de retraite a
pu garder un contact grâce à la
visioconférence sur son propre matériel
le temps lui a paru particulièrement
longs crocs pour beaucoup on atteint la
limite du supportable les sorties
c'était c'était conscrits
après quelques quelques personnes qui
ont pu sortir mais accompagnés du
personnel
aujourd'hui le retraité espère recevoir
de la visite dans les prochains jours le
pôle saint-hélier reste prudent dès la
semaine prochaine certaines mesures
sanitaires seront allégées mais avec une
vigilance accrue sur le maintien des
gestes barrières sur l'hygiène des mains
sur le port de masques et puis c'est
vrai que on privilégiera les visites
notamment sur des lieux extérieurs ou
dans des lieux des lieux dans les salles
à manger les lieux communs qui sont
aussi des pièces rafraîchies des salles
à manger des espaces de vie qui pourrait
être de nouveau mise à disposition des
résidents qui durant la crise du coc
vite 19 étaient confinés dans leur
chambre
le retour à la normale sera progressif
dans les 92 personnes âgées qui vivent
ici
voilà nous allons nous intéresser
maintenant à une marque que nous avons
tous portés notamment lorsque nous
étions plus jeunes
la marque petit bateau fondée en 1924 et
bien malgré la crise les activités de
logistique et de confection de petits
bateaux ne se sont jamais arrêtés
et c'est au delà de la fabrication des
masques réalisés à 3 dans l'entrepôt
logistique de but faire dans l'aube que
les commandes ont augmenté de 150%
notamment les commandes en ligne
la réouverture des 400 boutiques dans le
monde ont nécessité le recrutement
d'intérimaires
comme le montre ce reportage de nos
confrères sur place de canal 32 dans
l'aube
l'activité de petits bateaux ne s'est
jamais arrêté et aujourd'hui elle tourne
à plein régime
ici à buchères passe au centre
logistique de 40 mille mètres carrés une
équipe de trente volontaires a maintenu
un minimum d'expédition en ligne cette
équipe a rapidement été renforcée depuis
le 16 mars jusqu'à aujourd'hui dont
j'ai pas eu d'arrêt et les masques et
les gels et l'a10 tentation qu'on a
respecté dès le départ donc
l'inquiétude s'est vite envolée en fait
durant le confinement on a expédié à peu
près 300 me lever c'est donc ce sont des
unités de vente consommateurs pour la
partie e-commerce à peu près 180 minutes
et c'est pour la partie gms le japon
dont 70 milles ubc et aussi des clients
ce qu'on appelle le moule celle pour à
peu près 70 milles baissé à la vente en
ligne a augmenté de 150% donc
aujourd'hui les commandes sur internet
ont vraiment explosé durant le
confinement 95 % du parc magasins
étaient fermés depuis l'animé le réseau
de 400 boutiques à travers le monde a
rouvert et bien là nous sommes plutôt
heureux de ce qui se passe puisque nous
avons une très belle reprise dans nos
boutiques qui s'accompagne d'une
toujours d'une activité très importante
sur internet
quand on vient de vivre les deux mois
qui viennent de s'écouler on est très
modeste et très humble sur toutes les
prévisions
on a fait appel de nouveau travail
temporaire donc on a plus d'une centaine
de collaborateurs intérimaires qui sont
sur site la depuis depuis fin mai on est
même passé en équipe de nuit
occasionnels et on le travaille même les
samedis matin en lien avec le service se
sentait sécurité les salariés ont
participé à la mise en place d
adaptation face au coc u19 tous les
espaces de travail ont été repensés donc
quand une ouvrière francs une machine
différente elle désinfecte toute la
machine à laver de l'espace perdu au
sous-sol qu'on a optimisé ce qui nous a
permis d'élargir l'espace entre les
différentes machines et du contre chaque
opérateur
ensuite on a créé en fait des
protections anti projections les
machines étaient beaucoup plus
rapprochée peuple ouvrière avait terminé
son bac
le poussait sur le chemin rouleau
aujourd'hui quand elle a terminé son bal
des mois qui vient le chercher
qu'on ait le moins de déplacements
possibles de cette période des
personnels retiennent des liens
renforcés à la fois entre les équipes et
entre les acteurs de la filière textile
audoise voilà les data center quand on
les appelle maintenant ne sont pas
réservées à la capitale et à paris
allons découvrir à présent le premier
datacenter de moselle direction la ville
de peltre et plus précisément à quelques
pas de l'hôpital
merci trois salles informatiques sont à
disposition des futurs clients comme les
entreprises de la région où les
collectivités locales bien sûr 15000
serveurs peuvent être connectés en ligne
c'est beaucoup bien sûr la sécurité de
l'installation est primordial toutes les
explications avec nos confrères sur
place de via mirabel en regarder les
lumières scintillent depuis aujourd'hui
le premier datacenter demoiselle est
opérationnel et accueille ses premiers
serveurs donc là je vous présente donc
les premiers serveurs qui est qui n'aime
être installée donc là vous avez les
serveurs physiques et quand on parle de
clouds et de la virtualisation qu'on met
dans ses serveurs physiques et dans ce
domaine on part vite dans des termes
techniques est concrètement une photo
prise avec votre téléphone est déposé
sur le cloud pourrait être stocké ici à
quelques pas de l'hôpital de mercy en
périphérie de metz advance
médiomatriques se prépare à mettre à la
location 312 b pour accueillir les
serveurs des entreprises et
collectivités
nous voici dans l'une des trois salles
informatiques de cold corridor ils sont
installés vide pour le moment les baies
de différentes capacités vont accueillir
des serveurs dans les jours à venir
des espaces sécurisés les équipements
sont doublés temps sur l'alimentation
électrique que sur la connexion fibre
aujourd'hui tout héros don d imaginer si
le premier jour des soldes
votre site internet il n'est pas
disponible vous perdez un énorme chiffre
d'affaires pour une société qui
travaille aujourd'hui maintenant
principalement avec de l'informatique on
est obligé d'avoir comme ça une roue de
secours
la roue de secours c'est toujours le
dédoublement des liens ou de l'écrit
they advance medio matrix et la d4
datacenter de france à disposer de ce
niveau de sécurité il est labellisé
tiers 3 c'est-à-dire qu'ils assurent une
disponibilité d'au moins 99 points 982%
sans interruptions de connexion mais la
sécurité est aussi de mise dans le
bâtiment caméra et lecteurs de badges
sont omniprésents dans cette forteresse
de 2700 mètres carrés on va dire s'est
construit comme une prison aux prêtres
c'est très sécurisé bien sûr il ya la
sûreté de data aujourd'hui le coeur
d'une entreprise c'est aussi ces data
mais aussi parce que nous avons demandé
et nous travaillons pour être certifié
hébergeur de données de santé ou là on
doit prouver en fait il de kiêu et à
quel moment dans la bassin dans une
prison c'est peu dire dès l'entrée le
ton est donné avec ses grilles en guise
de cloisons une architecture qui marque
pour un lieu qui lui doit se faire
discret voilà c'est un message urgent à
présent que nous délivrons depuis le
déconfinement le don du sang connaître
une nette baisse de fréquentation dans
notre pays une nouvelle campagne
nationale a été lancée à l'initiative de
l'établissement français du sang
un mois durant lequel les donneurs sont
invités à se rendre dans les centres de
collecte près de chez eux
comme c'est le cas dans ce centre
sportif de calvi en corse où les équipes
de tv pas aisée on tournait ce reportage
regarder avant il y avait la journée
mondiale des donneurs de sang le 14 juin
et là en fait on entoure cette journée
mondiale par un mois de promotion du don
au début du confinement on a vu arriver
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de monde
cette affluence et petit à petit
hamon dit c'est à dire que on a vu les
collectes se déserté au fur et à mesure
du confinement et depuis la reprise de
l'activité alors c'est carrément une
désinfection des collectes
tant et si bien que les stocks sont en
train de faire une chute vertigineuse
mais un stock qui est très bas on a
besoin de poche de tous les groupes
surtout l'europe et nous sommes adaptés
en entretenant des salles le problème
des salles c'est qu'elles sont souvent
excentrés elles ne sont pas visibles et
donc nous n'avons pas cet attrait pour
quelqu'un qui passerait par là qu'il
dira tiens y'a le don du sang je vais y
aller
et donc il nous manque vraiment ces
nouveaux donneurs quelles sont les
étapes
l'accueil l'inscription leurs hommes
préfèrent dépressionnaire l'entretien
médical le prélèvement la collation ce
qui a de plus ce sont des gestes
barrières c'est à dire on arrive un
masque est fournie par le ffs
systématiquement ensuite qui a c'est
qu'on nettoie beaucoup plus c'est à dire
qu'à chaque passage du donneur le bureau
médical est nettoyé ensuite le lit de
prélèvement il avait à chaque passage et
les à la collation il ya des sept qui
sont changés à chaque donneur également
chaque collecte maintenant est organisée
avec rza denses et donc une application
qui permet de réserver son créneau
horaire pour venir donner son sang pour
qu'ils aient pas d'attentes donc il n'y
ait pas d'afflux massif de donneurs et
donc que la distance puisse être
respectés sans aucun problème mais les
gens qui se présentent spontanément
c'est pas pour autant que nous allons
les refoulés soit il ya de la place
au moment où ils arrivent et ils le sont
moins que dit son prix donnent leur sang
dans la foulée si vraiment il ya de la
tante de façon trop importante entre en
leurs coordonnées et on leur donne un
nouveau rendez vous pour venir vous
donnez du sang prenait le relais aidez
nous fait venir du monde
je passe le relais à quelqu'un pour que
lui aussi à faire cette bonne action on
a besoin de vous nos malades ont besoin
de vous
oui je rappelle que l'un deux sens et
trois vies sauvées
voilà après la corse direction la côte
d'azur son climat ses baignades ses
plages direction la célèbre plage
niçoise de beaurivage une institution de
la riviera les équipes de chic tv monte
carlo était présente à sa réouverture
les dirigeants et les habitués ont
retrouvé le sourire et le soleil comme
le montre ce reportage de stéphane attia
et de bruno alberti à nice l'activité
des plages a repris début juin la
direction de la plage beau rivage d'une
des plus anciennes de la promenade des
anglais nous explique comment réussir
cette saison avec les nouvelles
contraintes sanitaires et sans clientèle
internationale
les obligations sont très importantes
quand même on a une protocole qui a été
mis en place par la fédération des
restaurateurs que nous appliquons c'est
à dire 1 mètre 50 entre chaque transat 1
m 20 entre chaque table des sens de
circulation dans la plage entrées
sorties n'ont croisé dans les cuisines
dirigé par le chef alexandre oliveira
les nouvelles normes sanitaires impose
également un certain nombre de
contraintes
si vous voulez sur la chasse cp en
cuisine ça correspond déjà beaucoup
maintenant il ya le port du masque
malgré tout antoine attias le directeur
général de la plage reste positif par
rapport à l'histoire de l'établissement
j'ai essayé j'espère avoir réussi en
partie à préserver son historique en la
mettant dans la modernité en même temps
on engageait un grand chef
on monte en gamme chaque année c'est sam
ans
c'est ça mon but j'aime bien quand je me
retourne d'une année sur l'autre manière
c'est encore plus beau que l'année
dernière je considère que je me suis là
que pour un petit moment par rapport à
l'histoire du prix d'achat ne vivra plus
longtemps que moi
voilà pour la côte d'azur on pratique
peu le surf sur la côte d'azur le
pratiquer ton dans la sarthe
eh bien oui grâce au surf électronique
en sarthe on surf bien qu'on ne soit pas
au bord de l'océan est la première école
de surf électrique sur rivière a ouvert
ses portes dans le grand ouest
démonstrations à la suze avec diane
moisson de via lmt les sarthe qui a
emporté sa planche avec elle les ir et
sensations fortes garanties dès la
première séance promesses tenues avec
cette nouvelle technologie une planche
de surf
il ya un mois une hélice est une elle
capable d'aller jusqu'à 40 km heure donc
on a la gâchette là en fait on a déjà pu
dessus j'avance ça c'est ce qui nous
permet d'avoir de la propulsion d'avancé
ensuite pour pour se diriger
c'est un peu comme un bodyboard au bord
de la mer dans un premier temps si on
est allongé en faisant des appuis comme
ça sur les sur les côtés on fait tourner
la planche du côté où on se penche
il ya très peu de bruit puisque le
moteur est déjà émergé de plus un moteur
électrique en plus donc là on peut on
peut passer sur la rivière là on y
aurait un iphone qui passe derrière nous
on ne l'entendrait pas en terme de deux
vagues ça fait pas beaucoup plus de
vagues en fait que les bateaux habituel
quand la planche et au contact de l'eau
à partir du moment la planche se lève là
il ya quasiment aucune trace de sillage
d'une durée d'une heure quinze
chaque session se fait accompagné d'un
moniteur en liaison radio
une nouvelle activité dont se réjouit
certes touristes nous avons un
territoire qui offre une diversité
d'activités et là c'est une première en
france sur une rivière et ça se passe en
sarthe donc on est très fiers de cet
entrepreneur qui a innové
évidemment on a ensuite des gens qui
vont venir dormir des gens qui vont
venir quand les restaurants qui vont
aller voir d'autres activités c'est
complémentaire on n'est pas loin du zoo
de la flèche c'est complémentaire
donc vous vous organiser votre séjour et
vous avez comme ça vous piochez dans
toutes les pépites du département pour
avec vos familles découvrir la sarthe
l activité est accessible à partir de 16
ans pratiquer un autre sport de glisse
comme le ski ou le surf est évidemment
un plus
je commette à genoux facilement ça tiens
ça tient à peu près bien voilà pareil
toujours vu mon gabarit moi du coup je
j'ai besoin d'un peu de vitesse pour me
mettre debout faut prévoir quand même de
tomber à l'eau où on peut éventuellement
envisager de rester au sec sur une
cession il faut je pense venir en se
disant que les cheveux seront mouillés
si vous n'avez pas peur de vous mouiller
les séances démarre à la mi juin
comptait 65 euros pour une session et
des forfaits pour ceux qui deviendront
accroc voilà merci d'avoir suivi ce dont
j'étais des territoires sur vos chaînes
de télévision locales et régionales ou
sur tv5 monde dans 200 pays et en 14
langues
on se retrouve bien sûr pour une
prochaine édition à très vite au revoir
et bon courage
[Musique]